[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلو هذا ابرز
العناوين
هتلر
كتكوت
يلجا الى مخازينه السريه في اسرائيل
لامداد الجيش الاوكراني
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يشدد على ضروره
اعاده الهدنه في اليمن ويؤكد على اقناع
الحوثيين بالسلام بانه سيفتح الباب امام
محل سياسي
الاضرابات تتعب القطاعات الحيويه في دول
ماشا الصحه والتعليم في بريطانيا والتقاعد
والنقل في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
في رد على الرئيس الروسي قال الامين العام
لحلف الناتو ينزتون
لم يظهر اي اشاره استعداد للسلام ويجب ان
يدرك انه لن يفوز بالحرب ضد اوكرانيا
واضاف السلطن برج ان المشاورات مستمره بين
الحلفاء لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه
كما ان اكياس بحاجه الى انظمه دفاعا جوي
وذخيره والصيانه للاسلحه التي يرسلها
الحلف بدونه وصف وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الغربيه اسلاميه الامريكيه منها في
اوكرانيا بتصرفاته هتلر قبل ذلك قال
الرئيس الروسي ان اوكرانيا مارست الخداع
اكثر من مره وهي اكياس من دفعت بموسكو الى
الحرب وفقه قوي بوتن بوتين قال ان الهدف
من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
هو انهاء المعاناه والحرب المستمره منذ
سنوات
لم تتوقف العمليات القتاليه التي تشمل
الاسلحه الثقيله والمدفعيه والدبابات
والطائرات في دمباز منذ 2014 ما نقوم به
اليوم كجزء من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو
ومحاوله لوقف هذه الحرب وحمايه شعبنا الذي
يعيش في تلك المناطق لقد تحملنا لفتره
طويله وحاولنا التوصل الى اتفاق لكن تم
خداعنا وهذه ليست المره الاولى ومع ذلك
بدلنا قصار جهدنا لحل هذا الوضع بالوسائل
السلميه العدو كان يستعد لتحويل الصراع
برمته الى مرحله حاده وساخنه اكرر لم يكن
لدينا خيار سوى ان نفعل ما نقوم به الان
اعتبر الرئيس الاوكراني
ان تحطم مروحيه وزير الداخليه الاوكرانيه
ماساه مروعه لكن ما هو السيناريو المحتمل
الذي تسبب بسقوطها في التقرير التالي
ها وهم في طريقهم لبقعه ساخنه من القتال
مدينه بروفاريه الاوكرانيه اصبحت شاهده
على اللحظات الاخيره
دوله في وزاره الشؤون الداخليه
لجهاز الدوله حدثت الواقعه بالقرب من
العاصمه كيف في مدينه بروفاريه على بعد 20
كيلو مترن شمال شرق العاصمه تسببت الحادثه
في سقوط 10 والمصابين بينهم اطفال متاثرين
باسطدام المروحيه بمبدا سكني وحضاره رسمي
السلطات الاوكرانيه تعمل على معرفه
ملابسات الحادثه وتجمع الادله فيما اعلنت
المانيا استعدادها للمشاركه في التحقيق
للوقوف على ما اذا كان الحادث مدبرا منه
بسبب عطل فني او بسبب الطقس
الجزيره بالذكر ان عمليه نقل المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين تتم اعاده بطائره مروحيه تحلق
على مستوى منخفض جدا ما قد ينطوي على
مخاطر عنده وفاه وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
التي تاتي وسط تصعد الحرب بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا قد تؤثر على عمل الحكومه مع
خسارتها وزير المختصه في مهام حيويه بينها
اداره الشرطه خلال الحرب
الى امكانيه الموافقه على منحها دبابات
المانيه متطوره في نهايه خطابه بمنتدى
دافوس تجنب شونس الاجابه عن تساؤل بشان
ارسال دبابات ليوبار تو التي طلبتها كياد
وقال ان برلين ستواصلوا دعم اوكرانيا
بالوسائل الماليه والمساعدات الانسانيه
والكثير من الاسلحه ولم يذكر شوز كلمه
دبابات كما لم يدلي بتصريحات حول الشماع
دعم اوكرانيا المقرر الجمعه في القاعده
الامريكيه في المانيا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو كاتيا طعمه
مراسلات العربيه ومنكياب حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه سابدا معك حذيفه واخر التطورات
بحادثه سقوط مروحيات وزير الداخليه
الاوكراني الى ماذا افضت التحقيقات
الرسميه حتى الساعه
مساء الخير
بعد تكهنات كثيره وحديث في القنوات
الاوكرانيه وفي مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
حول ما اذا ما كان هذه حادثه ام بفعل طبعا
الرئيسكي قبل قليل في المنتدى الاقتصاد
العالمي في ذا فويس عبر مداخل عبر
الانترنت قال بشكل واضح ان هذه الحادثه او
مقتل همم وزير الداخليه من الستيرس هذه
ليست بحادثه قال هذه حرب حقيقيه والحرب
يمكن ادارتها بطرق عده في اشاره الى ان
هذه الحادثه كانت مدبره طبعا الحديث حول
هذه الحادثه الجهاز الامن الوطني فتح
تحقيق حول هذه الحادثه وقال انه لديه همم
ثلاثه همم يعني همم يبحث في ثلاثه اتجاهات
اولا هو ان يكون هذه همم فعلا الاحوال
الجويه او حادثه عابره او ان يكون هذا
بتخريب او بفعل فاعل طبعا ايضا نفذ اداره
الطوارئ ان يكون هنالك يعني ما نشرته يقول
بشكل واضح انه لم يكون هناك استهداف في
الجو بعد ان انه لا لم يكن هنالك حريق في
هذه المروحيه في الجو وانما الحريق حدث
بعد همم هذه المروحيه طبعا ايضا تحقق امن
الدوله يحقق في مساله البروتوكول ومساله
يعني خرق القواعد في همم مثل هذه الظروف
خاصه في ظروف الحرب طبعا اداره الطوارئ
قالت ان هذه المروحيه هي مروحيه الطوارئ
وهذه المروحيه والطاقم عملوا في ظروف جويه
صعبه جدا
واستطاعوا ان
يجعلوا عدد من المواطنين في ظروف مختلفه
هم جاهزين للعمليات الصعبه وقد كانوا
جاهزين في هذه المهمه لاداء المهمه في
ظروف صعبه هذا ايضا يحيي ويستبعد عمليه
هذه الطائره قد سقط نتيجه حادث عربي ولا
انا الطائره طبعا هي اصلا طائره همم
طارق هذا من جانبي طبعا بقى اليوم ايضا او
مجلس الوزراء الاوكراني اتخذ القرار
بتعيين يهرق الامينكو همم مدير الشرطه
الوطنيه همم نائب لوزير الداخليه وتم
تكليفه من قبل مجلس الوزراء بالتشاور مع
البرلمان طبعا بتكليفه بي مهام وزير
الداخليه والى ان يتم تعيين وزير للداخليه
جديد وهذا الامر همم بعض الاليات بتشاور
مع البرلمان الاكرانيا هل همم طبعا عدد
الضحايا اختلف تماما من نشرته الرسميه
الان لدينا 14 قتيلا بينهم طفل واحد
وهنالك ما يقرب من جريحا ولكن كبيره
الاطباء في المستشفى التي نقل اليه الجرح
قال ان لديه خمسه من الجرح في حاله حر جدا
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال في حاله حرجه وشخصان
بالغين همم في حاله حرجه لديهم 30% جروح
في الجسم بما فيها جروح في الجهاز التنفسي
همم من عندك حذيفه سانتقل الى كاتا كات هل
هناك اي تعليق او موقف في موسكو حول هذه
الحادثه وايضا يعني على المقلب الاخر هناك
حرب كلاميه بين موسكو وبين الغرب موضوع
التسليح بموضوع طول وامد الحرب كل اجواء
من هناك معك
مرحبا
لم يتم التعليق من جانب روسيا على هذه
الحادثه فقد تناولتها وسائل الاعلام روسيه
طبعا هذا من جانب امام جانب اخر طبعا
بالنسبه لتسليحه الذي همم تنوي او تنوي
الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو عشان التزويد
به اوكرانيا روسي ميرارا كانت قد تحدثت
انها همم طبعا همم هذا التزويد الدائم
وهذا الزخم بكميه الاسلحه هو سيطل فقط من
العمليه العمليه العسكريه واليوم كان وزير
الخارجيه روسي قد علق خلال المؤتمر الصحفي
الموسع الذي عقده لنتائج دبلوماسيه
الروسيه ان اا واشنطن طبعا همم هي تسع
لتقويد روسيا من خلال باستخدامه او
استغلال اوكرانيا ومن خلال تزويدها
بالاسلحه هتطيل العمليه العسكريه هناك وهي
تقضي على الشعب الاوكراني بنفسه وليس فقط
روسيا وطبعا تاكيدات الرئيس الروسي اليوم
جاءت همم
بان رو ستستمر في هذه العمليه العسكريه
وانها بالتاكيد ستنتصر فيها على الرغم من
التزويد الدائم للدول الغربيه ولواشنطن
بالاسلحه المتنوعه لاوكرانيا ليال نعم
شكرا لكما مراسلي العربيه كاتيا طعمه من
موسكو وحذيفه عادل من كاس
نقلتها الولايات المتحده في الاشهر
الاخيره مئات الالاف من قذائف المدفعيه من
مخزونها من الذخيره في اسرائيل الى
اوكرانيا وفقا ما كشفت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه الذخيره التي تم نقلها
الى اوكرانيا كانت جزءا من مخزون الاسلحه
الامريكيه التي تم تخزينها مسبقا في
مستودعات في اسرائيل كجزء من اتفاقيه بين
الدولتين الصحيفه الامريكيه اكدت ان هذه
الخطوه هي جزء من جهه كبير قام به
البنتاجون لاعاده امداد الجيش الاوكراني
الذي يحتاج الى عشرات الالاف من قباء في
المدفعيه كل شهر لحربه ضد روسيا التي
تعتبر فيها نيران المدفعيه عنصرا رئيسا
مسؤولون اسرائيليون قالوا لموقع اكسيوس ان
البنتاجون اثار القضيه معه مسارات الدفاع
الاسرائيليه قبل نحو اربعه اشهر واكد ان
هذه الاخيره هي ملك للولايات المتحده ولا
تحتاج الى اذن من اسرائيل في المقابل
مشاهدينا كشف مسؤول اسرائيل بدون اخرون ان
القلق الرئيسي وان روسيا ستعتبر هذه
الخطوه بمثابه مساعده عسكريه من جانب
اسرائيل لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من تل ابيب عليما المحلل العسكري اام
سابدا من موضوع الاسلحه طبعا يعني هي
اسلحه امريكيه بارض تعتبر امريكيه ونقلت
من هناك بطائرات امريكيه وهذا ما تعمد
الجانب الاسرائيلي توضيحه بالساعات
الماضيه عبر التسريبات ماذا يعني ذلك وهل
يمكن ان يسبب اي ازمه مع موسكو
هذا هو القلق في اسرائيل في الواقع هذه
القضيه تربه في اسرائيل الى درجه كبيره
ونحن نعرض الحساسيه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات
مع روسيا خاصه على خلفيه الحمى في
اوكرانيا منذ بدا هذه الحرب امتنعت
اسرائيل عن اتخ
اذها اوك
رانيا لاوكرانيا حتى الاسلحه الدفاعيه
ويتذكرني بماضي المضادات الدفاعيه التي اا
من اسرائيل ولكن الصعيد رفضت ذلك خشه
ذلك الى العلاقات
اسرائيل بالدرجه الاولى يتعلق بالاوظائف
في سوريا كما نعلم
ان يؤدي ذلك
موجود على حريه ينشطها في المجال الجوي
السوري وفي الواقع هذا ما يبقى قصيد ولكن
في هذا الموضوع الصغير لا تستطيع ان تفعل
شيئ عند
الجمل بانها ملك امريكي استاذ
التسريب بهذا التوقيت مع حكومه نتنياهو
بالذات مع انها حصلت بوقت الحكومه السابقه
هل يمكن القول بان العلاقه بين بيض وهذه
الحكومه عنوانها الاحراج العلني الغير
مباشره
اولا هناك علامات استفهام بالنسبه لها
علاقات بين اسرائيل والاداره الامريكيه
خاصه نحن نعلم التوتر القائمه بين يتنياهم
شخصيا وبين الحزب الديمقراطي وكذلك بين مع
رئيس الرئيس الامريكي لذلك لا يبدو انه لم
ياتي بشكل المجتمع بان يتم هذا الترسيم
بناء على التوتر المحتمل همم المستشار
للامن القومي يزول حاليا اسرائيل بطبيعه
الحاله سوف يدور الحديث حول قضايا مختلفه
بظنها هذه القضيه نحن نعلم ان الولايات
الم لقد اعرضت ان تحافظاتها من موقف
اسرائيل بشان الحره في اوكرانيا يعتق
د انوفيتغير بسبب هذه القضيه
العسكريه نتحدث عن اعطاء اسلحه من مخزون
امريكي في الشرق الاوسط وهي ايضا كانت قد
اعطت اسرائيل قبل ست سنوات من هذا المخزون
بحربه ام يعني من الناحيه العسكريه بعيدا
عن الشوق السياسي وامر طبيعي
صحيح من ناحيه اسرائيل الحقيقه بان هذا
المخزون يتوا
يعتبر جزء من علاقتها المميزه
وتعتك مخزون
للاسلحه حيث تستطيع ان تستخدمه نذكر انه
قبل بد
عه فقط
الموجوده في المستودعات في اسرائيل من
ناحيه اسرائيل تعت بقى لك الركنه الهاما
في
قدراتها الاصليه
بالمنحه السياسي
واوكرانيا منذ الحرب ان تشهد
نوع من عدم الارتياح في اجانب الاوكراني
من الموقف الاسرائيلي وكانت هناك تصريحات
واضحه بهذا الصدر
لا يلوم قال همم الحكومه الايصاليه بانها
تتخذ هذا الموقف دون ابداء التضامن مع
القضيه الاوكرانيه نظرانا
وخاصه على من المنطلق الاخلاقي بان ما
يحدث من هذه الحمى في في اوكرانيا
المحل العسكري حدثنا من تل ابيب
وحش روسي في سماء اوكرانيا نتحدث هنا عن
صاروخ كروز كي اتش 1 2 الذي عجزت اوكرانيا
عن التصدي له لانها لا تملك اي اسلحه او
دفاعات جويه قادره على اسقاطه كما تقول لك
هذا الصاروخ اطلقته القوات الروسيه في
هجمتها الاخيره على مدينه نيبرو على من
خمسه قاذفات بعيده المدى من تراث تي يو
اتش تو mp3 وتم تنفيذ عمليات الاطلاق من
منصه ومن منطقه كورس ومن مياه بحر اسف
صاروخ كروز من طراز كي اتش ون تو يعتبر
احد اقوى صواريخ التي تمتلكها روسيا يبلغ
وزنه نحو 950 كيلو جراما ويصل مداه الى
نحو 600 كيلومت بدا تطوير هذا الصاروخ
مشاهدينا عام
1958 بهدف تدمير حاملات الطائرات هي
ومجموعات حاملات الطائرات القتاليه ان ذلك
ويمكن حمل واطلاق الصاروخ عبر قذفات
متوسطه المدى ويستخدم هذا الصاروخ ويستخدم
ايضا الوقود السائل الذي تصل سرعته الى
524 كيلو متر بالساعه روسيا قامت في عام
وفي تحويل ترسنتها من هذا الصاروخ الى
التخزين قبل ان تعيد استخدامه مع بدايه
عملياتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا التي بدات
في فبراير الماضيه
[موسيقى]
وفي خبر متعلق بالحرب باوكرانيا ايضا افاد
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان الفرقه 25
التابعه للنظام الاسد تشارك في مهمات
قتاليه خارجيه لصالح روسيا ويرجح نشطاء ان
تكون المهمه في اوكرانيا المرصد كشف ان
الفرقه حصلت على رواتب عناصرها من مخصصات
جيش النظام بناء على امر من غرفه العمليات
المشتركه الروسيه السوريه بحسب وثيقه سريه
حصل عليها المرصد وتؤكد الوثيقه بان رواتب
عناصر الفرقه الخامسه والعشرين صرفت لعدم
توفر القطاع القطعه الاجنبي والميزانيه
اللازمه لتسديد رواتب شهريه لشهر نوفمبر
وادي السمسمبر من العام الماضي ووفقا
لمصادر المرصد بدات مشاركه الفرقه الخامسه
والعشرين في العمليات العسكريه ضمن
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا شرقيه
اوكرانيا بعد نقلهم طبعا من سوريا الى
روسيا عبر مطار حميميم واضاف المرصد ان
عدد السوريين الذين الذين جندتهم روسيا في
حرب اوكرانيا بلغ نحو الفيس السوري
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
البرلمان الاوروبي
على قوائم العقوبات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان على انه لا
يمكن انهاء الحرب في اليمن الا من خلال حل
يتم الاتفاق عليه بين الاطراف مضيفا من
خلال مشاركته بمنتدى دافوس ان اقناع
الحوثيين بالسلام سيفتح الباب امام محل
سياسي
كونان لا يمكن انهاء الحرب الا من خلال حل
نتفق عليه وهذا ما نعمل عليه حاليا
المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده المعني
باليمن موجود هنا وحكومه اليمن تسعى ايضا
لايجاد وسيله للاتفاق مع الحوثيين للوصول
الى وقف اطلاق النار والوصول الى نهايه
هذه الازمه
من جهه شدد المبعوث
على ضروره انهاء الصراع في اليمن مؤكدا
انه تسبب في معاناه الملايين مشيرا خلال
جلسه النقاشيه في منتدى دافوس الى ان
الهدف هو ايجاد الوسيله لتحقيق ذلك
لانهاء الصراع كيف وعلى اي اسس هذه امور
يمكن تفاوض بشانها الخطوات التي تم
احرازها كانت ايجابيه في الاشهر الاخيره
حيث خفض صوت السلاح لكن الموضوع لم ينتهي
والطريقه لا يزال طويلا
[موسيقى]
اعلن اتصلتات الافغانيه ارتفاع عدد وفيات
موجه البرد القارس التي تضرب البلاد الى
70 شخصا على الاقل خلال اسبوع وتشهد كابول
والعديد من الولايات الاخرى انخفاض
الحراره وصلت في بعض المناطق الى 33 درجه
تحت الصفر وتسبب تساقط الثلوج بكثافه في
قطع طرق بعده ولايات في وسط افغانستان
وشمالها في وقت يواجه اكثر من نصف الافغان
انعدام الامن الغذائيه الحاد
وفي لقائه مع مندوبي الامم المتحده في
كابول قال وزير خارجيه حكومه طالبان امير
خان متقي ان العقوبات وعقوبات المجتمع
الدولي تقيد النظام المصرفي في البلاد
يجب ان ارضيك انت وحكومتي وشعبي والان
تخبرني بما فعله المجتمع الدولي تم فرد
عقوبات على افغانستان وهناك قيود على
النظام المصري والتجار يواجهون مشاكل عده
ولا يمكنهم حتى تحويل الاموال لشراء
الطعام
[موسيقى]
الغت المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل تعيين
وزير الداخليه ريا درعي في حكومه نتنياهو
لازانته بالاحتيال وذكرت تقارير ان القرار
تم اتخاذه داخل للمحكمه العليا باسرائيل
باغلبيه 10 قضاه مقابل رفض قادم واحد ويعد
درعي رئيس حزب شاز احد الداعمين الرئيسيين
لان نتنياهو بما يزيد حدد التوترات
المتفاقمه بالفعل بين حكومته والمحكمه
العليا في اسرائيل بسبب خطه اصلاح قضائيه
مثيره للجدل
ضربه قويه لاتلاف لتنيياه الحكومي من
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه التي قررت
باغلبيه 10 قضاه في مقابل معارضه واحد
الغاء تعيين رئيس حزب شاس ريا درعي وزيرا
في الحكومه بسبب ادانته في قضيه فساد ما
يعني انعل نتنياهو ان يقيله من منصبه وما
يعني ايضا بان الحرب على النظام القضائي
التي تسميها الحكومه اصلاحات ستستعر ازواج
دستوريه وربما ايضا اجمل ثلاثيه ولكن مما
لا شك فيه هناك ازمه بين السلطه القضائيه
والسلطه التنفيذيه هي الحكومه في سبب
اقاله الوزير همم
اللافته ان قرار المحكمه العليا جاء رغم
قيام وزير العدل الاسرائيلي بعرض خطه
اضعاف القضاء عشيه المداولات في ملف درعي
معتبر تهديدا للنظام القضائي الاسرائيلي
الذي احاكم نتنياهو في ثلاث قضايا فساد
يتجاوزت كل الحدود بالتدخل في قانون اساسي
اقر باغلبيه 63 شخصا عكس رغبه الاغلبيه
للاسف المحكمه العليا تعتقد بانها حاكم
خفي لاسرائيل
تخالف القانون وحكومه لا تلتزم بالقانون
هي حكومه غير قانونيه
الائتلاف سيسرع التشريعات المتعلقه
بالقضاء بهدف محاوله اعاده درع الى منصبه
ومن بينها تغليب قرارات الكنيست على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه للسياسيين من
الاحتلال في لجنه تعيين القضاء والغاء
فقره المعقوليه القضائيه كالتي حسمت امر
درعي باعتبار انه غير معقول ان يبقى وزيرا
بعد ادانته المتكرره بقضايا فساد الملك
المعركه بين التوليفه الحاكمه في اسرائيل
ونظام القضائيه شهدت نقله نوعيه بالغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه توزير درعي
تصب الزيت على نار المواجهه الدائره في
البرلمان وفي الشارع الاسرائيلي ايضا زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
بايران يدرس البرلمان الاوروبي مشروع قرار
يدعو لادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
والبسيج على قوائم الارهاب مشروع اضافه
لادراج على قوائم العقوبات في دورها حذرت
منظمه العفو الدوليه من ان حياه عشرات
المحتاجين في ايران في خطر لانهم يواجهون
احكام بالاعدام على راسهم الشعب المتظاهر
محمد اقبادله الذي يعتقل خلال الاحتجاجات
الجاريه هذا وداعه المنظمه طهران الى
التراجع عن هذه القرارات التي تنهي حياه
المحتاجين السلمي»
[موسيقى]
وعلى ذكرى عمليات الاعدام الاخيره في
ايران تعود بالذاكره الى عام
1988 جمهوريه الاعدامات التي كان ابراهيم
رئيسي يشرف عليها انذاك وهذه الجمهوريه
عادت الان حيث لا يجرا فيها الناس على
الاحتجاج ولا يجرؤ فيها المسؤولون على
الانشقاق تقول مجموعه انترناشونال كرايسز
لرويترز هنا مشهد الاعدامات في ايران وضع
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسه بمواجهه
المحليه وعالميه واعاده بالذاكره الى
قرارات رئيسي عندما كان عضوا في لجان
الموت التي اشرفت على اعدام مئات المساجين
السياسيين في العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
وافقه طبعا هنا منظمات حقوقيه لشفاء عيسى
على قمع حاد للاحتجاجات اليوم ويقول عنها
مراقبون انها تسببت بمقتل 500 شخص من
متظاهرين ورجال الامن وهذا يردد صدى الدور
الذي لعبه رئيس الايراني في اباده السجناء
السياسيين في عام
1988 وحينها وبعد اسابيع من الهدنه اطلاق
النار في يوليو والتي انهى الثماني سنوات
من حرب مضميه مع العراق اعدمت السلطات
الايرانيه سرا وبشكل جماعي الاف السجناء
من المعارضين المهددين بالنظام الايراني
وشكل وقتها النظام ما اصبح يعرف باسم لجان
الموت في كافه ارجاء ايران والتي تكونت
مشاهدينا من قضاه دينيين ومددعين ومسؤولين
وخبراء استخبارات لتحديد مصير الاف
المعتقلين في
كما تعسفيه استغرقت دقائق فقط وفقا طبعا
لتقرير نشراته منظمات العفو الدوليه
واليوم وبعد حوالي ثلاثه عقود تتخوف ايضا
المنظمات الحقوقيه من ان ينجح النظام
الايراني من السيطره على الاحتجاجات التي
ترهب الناس بالاعدامات سرا وعلانيه
[موسيقى]
قال النائب في البرلمان الايراني اسماعيل
كوثري انه يجب على دول اوروبا اثبات
استقلالها عن الولايات المتحده ومعارضه اي
عمل ضد الحرس الثوري الايراني مشيرا بان
ادراج الحرس الثوري ضمن قائمه الجماعات
الارهابيه يغلقوا اي باب للحوار والتفاوض
مهددان بان ايران تعلم ما يجب عليها ومن
يجب عليها فعله اذا قام الاتحاد الاوروبي
بهذا الفعل
[موسيقى]
عبر الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف الرشيد عن
رفضه للخروقات التركيه للحدود واكد انها
تضع الحكومه المركزيه وحكومه اقليم
كردستان في حرج واضاف رشيد ان الموقف
التركي من اجتياح الاراضي العراقيه لجيشها
او طيرانها يحرج حكومه العراق وحكومه
الاقليم ويمنع وجود علاقات طبيعيه وتطرق
الرئيس العراقي الى قضيه المياه حيث اكد
ضروره التوصل الى اتفاق مع تركيا بشان حصه
عادله من المياه اللي بيئته
التقى رئيس جهاز المخابرات التركيه هاكان
فيزان مع رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميد دبابه ورئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خالد المشرف طرابلس هذا واشار المشري الى
انه عقد ايضا اجتماع موسعا ضم الى جانب
للذبابه وفيدان نائب رئيس المجلس الرئاسي
ومحافظ مصرف ليبيا المركزي
في ليبيا
الاطراف السياسيه في مقتل فعلى القاضي اي
اتفاق جديد يولد خلاف اخر وسط التدخلات
خارجيه هذه المره ترمي تركيا بثقلها في
خلافات الغرب الليبي وساطه تركيه بين رئيس
الحكومه المنتهيه ولايته هو رئيس المجلس
الاعلى بين عبد الحميد البابا وخالد
المشري مصالحه تمت برعايه خالصه من رئيس
المخابرات التركيه الذي عقد اجتماعيا
منفصلين احدهما برئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه والاخر برئيس المجلس ليخت تمام
بلقاء صلح بعد الخلافات الاخيره
للانتخابات
سي يصرف المليارات ويقاتل عبد الحميد باي
بني منعها رئيس مجلس الدوله حدث بينه وبين
رئيس النواب تقارب اخر لكنه فشل بعد
تصريحات تعقيل صالح بان الاتفاق مع المشري
لا يتعدى ان يكون لفظيا تصريح قابله اخر
قطع ورقه الانعاش الاخيره بين شخصين لم
يتفق يوم اصلا في وقت تعود فيه المياه الى
مجارها بين الدبابه والمشري الاخير الذي
ادعم فتح بشار بقوه ثم توسع الجفاء ايضا
بينهما لاحقا
تحركات تركيه في الغرب الليبي تقابلها
تحركات امريكيه اخرى شرقا وغربا حيث زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه الى ليبيا في محاوله للجمع بين
خليفه حفتر وقوتي العسكريه وعبد الحميد
زبيبه وقوته سياسيه وذلك بعد اخر لا يغيب
عن التدخل التركي لتهدئه قيادات الغرب
وعقد هدنه بينهما في ظل الانتخابات
التركيه المرتقبه مع محاوله انقر المستمره
لايجاد موتى قدم لها في الشرق الليبي
وتامين مصالحها وسعيها للامساك بخيوط
التطورات السياسيه الليبيه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعلان استقلال البلاد عن الصين لان بلاده
ذات سياده مستقله بالفعل مشيرا بان تايوان
والصين لا يتبعان باي شكل من الاشكال لبعض
[موسيقى]
سياده ولا داعي لاعلان استقلال تايوان
بشكل منفصل تايوان والصين
لبعضهم البعض كما يمكن للشعب التايواني
23 شخص ان يقرر مستقبله
بعد الغواصات استراليا تتخلى عن مروحيات
فرنسيه
وتستبدلها ببلاك هوك الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تتسعوا رقعه الاضرابات
داخل القطاعات الحيويه في بريطانيا اذا
انضم المعلمون الى الاضرابات الى جانب كل
من الممرضين وعمال السكاك الحديديه وسيضرب
الاف المعلمين في فبراير ومارس المقبلين
بسبب الخلاف حول الاجور على الرغم من
التحذيرات من ان الاضراب
فيعرض الاطفال الضعفاء خصوصا للخطر وسيطلق
قاده النقابه الوطنيه للتعليم اكبر اتحاد
تعليمي في البلاد اضرابا بعد نتائج
التصويت من قبل اعضائه البالغ عددهم
300,000 هذا وصوت مشاهدينا تسعه من اصل 10
مدرسيين من نقابه المعلمين لصالح الاضراب
ويجتازت النقابه نسبه الاقبال البالغه 50%
التي يقتضيها القانون قطاع التمريض في
بريطانيا هو الاخر اعلن ان اضرابهم سيستمر
الى يوم غد الخميس مضيفين اي الممرضون ان
همم الاشخاص يتوف دون دعن في اشاره الى
تسبب الحكومه في هذه الوفيات كونها لا
تستجيب لمطالب رفع الاجور هذا وتواصل
الحكومه رفض التحدث الى الكليه الملكيه
لتمريض بخصوص الاجور والنقابات الصحيه
الاخرى حول تحسين زياده الاجور البالغه
1400 جنيه استرليني في الفتره من عام 2022
الى
2023 التي قدمت لموظفي هيئه او قدمت لموظف
هيئه الخدمات الوطنيه الصحيه الى الجانب
الاخر مشاهدينا من القناه الانجليزيه حيث
يستعد الفرنسيون للاحتجاج غدا ليكون خميسا
اسود كما اطلق عليه في اضراب سيكون عام
ويتسبب بالغاء معظم رحلات القطارات في
البلاد غدا الخميس مع تاثر رحله الجويه
وتعطل مترو الانفاق بشكل كبير في باريس
وذلك طبعا احتجاجا على اصدار مشروع الرئيس
الفرنسي الماني معكم الخاص باصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي تعتبر احدى نقاته الاساسيه
رفع سن التقاعد الاعتمادي من 62 عاما
حاليا الى 64 عاما بحلول عام 2030
[موسيقى]
لنقل الصوره اكثر عن هذه الاضطرابات ينضم
الينا من لندن مصطفى زار ومراس العربيه
وايضا من باريس فادي دهوك مراسل العربيه
ايضا سابدا معك مصطفى خارطه يعني
الاحتجاجات غدا وماذا في المفاوضات مع
السلطات الرسميه
بالنسبه للمفاوضات ليست هناك اي بوادر
ايجابيه بالرغم من ان اا اعضاء النقابات
المختلفه همم قالت بان من الافضل
الاستمرار في هذه المحادثات ولكن الجانب
السلبي وان تم الاعلان عن المزيد من هذه
الضربات في وقت تجري فيه المفاوضات مع
المسؤولين في الحكومه البريطانيه فيما
يتعلق مثلا
باضرابات جديده لاطقم الاسعاف تم التاكد
الان ان هناك
متتاليين ابتداء من السادس والسابع من
فبراير بالاضافه الى السادس
والعشرين من شهر
مارسوء الحظ بان هذا الاضرار في السادس من
همم فبراير المقبل سيصادف اضراب اخر
للممرضين في السادس وهذا سيكون له اثر
كبير على الخدمات الصحيه في في انجلترا
وويلز وهذا يعني بان هناك المزيد من
المشاكل ستواجه الناس ليس فقط الاتصال
بخدمات الطوارئ ولكن ايضا في الحصول على
العلاج او يعني المواعيد التي تم جدوالتها
نعرف بان الاضرابين المرضيين للممرضين تم
الغاء ما يقارب من 30,000 موعد لكن حمايه
العلاجات الكيميائيه لمرض السرطان
بالاضافه الى حديث همم الولاده ولكن هذا
ليس كافن بالرغم من ان نقابات تقول بانها
ستحاول تامين بعض الخدمات الصحيه الضروريه
لاولائك الذين يحتاجون في يوم في ايام
الاضطرابات
تناقش تشريع يحد من هذه الاضطرابات ويريد
وتريد الحكومه بان تكون هناك يعني مستويات
همم يعني متوفره لتقديم هذه الخدمات والحد
الادنى عندما الطوارئ بما فيها اا يعني
التمريض
والاسعاف بالاضافه الى خدمات رئيسيه اخرى
تعتمد عليها همم في مختلف القطاعات البلد
لاسيمه التي همم في التنقل مثلا ولكن هذه
بوادر سلبيه حتى هذه اللحظه بالاضافه الى
ان هناك ما يقرب من 100,000 موظف حكومي
بعضهم يعمل في وزاره الصحه والرعايه
الاجتماعيه الى جانب همم وزاره العمل
والمعاشات التقاعديه سيد يضربون في اول
يوم من فبراير بالاضافه كما ذكرت في
التقديم سيكون هناك اضراب للمعلمين همم
مصطفى ساعود اليك لنقل صوره التظاهر التي
هي في الخلفيه ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل الى
باليز والزميل فادي فادي ايضا الصوره
مماثله في باريس واضرابات ستنطلق غدا ما
المتوقع خارطه هذه الاضطرابات وهل نتوقع
تصيد فيها
مساء الخير ليال غدا سوف تبدا الموجه
الاولى من الاضرابات هناك ثلاث موجات حددت
حتى الان الاولى تبدا غدا والثانيه سوف
تكون في السادس والعشرين من هذا الشهر سوف
تستمر الى يومين اما الثالثه ستكون في
السادس من فبراير المقبل وسوف تكون ثلاثه
ايام اضرابات غد سوف تشمل معظم القطاعات
في فرنسا سوف تشمل قطاع الطاقه التعليم
السكك الحديديه المواصلات واكثر ما يقلق
الفرنسيين هو اضراب قطاع الطاقه لانه
يذكرهم بازمه الوقود التي همم ضربت البلاد
مؤخرا وايضا بدانا نشاهدها ان لحضرها
ابتداء من يومين تقريبا هناك ازدحام شديد
على محطات الوقود لان العاملين في محطات
اا
الوقود اعلنوا انهم سوف يشاركون في هذا
الاضراب لذلك هناك ازدحام بدانا نلاحظه
على محطات الوقود ايضا الى جانب هذا
الاضراب سوف يكون هناك
تحرك احتجاجي سوف يكون هناك مظاهرات ضخمه
جدا من المتوقع ان تكون ضخمه في معظم عموم
البلاد التظاهر المركزيه بالطبع سوف تكون
في باريس وهذه التظاهرات جاءت بدعوه من
ثمان نقابات عماليه قامت باصدار بيان موحد
دعت الى الاضراب والى المظاهرات ايضا هذه
المظاهرات هناك توقعات من اجهزه
الاستخبارات الفرنسيه بانها سوف تجمع ما
بين 500,000 الى 700,000 متظاهر وسوف يتم
نشر نحو عشره الاف شرطي في عموم الميلاد
لمواجهه همم هذه التظاهرات او احتمال حدوث
اعمال شغب ايضا بالمناسبه سوف يكون هناك
عدد من الاجهزه التابعه للشرطه ايضا سوف
تكون مشاركه في هذا الاضراب المشهد معقد
جدا لكن همم على العموم كل التوقعات سوف
تشير الى ان يوم غد سوف يكون خميس اسود
كما ذكرت في مقدمه النشره وهذا بدا لاحظه
سواء على محطات الوقود الانتظار الطويل
والسيارات التي بدات تتوجه الى هذه
المحطات وايضا في محطات المترو والقطارات
هناك عدد كبير من القطارات والمحطات بدات
الناس لا تستخدمها او تخشى من ان تعلق في
هذه المحطات اا ايضا هناك عدد من القطارات
في المشاهدات الاقليميه تم الغائه اليوم
واا ربما غدا سوف تكون همم البلاد مربكه
تماما وحركه المو- المرور سوف تكون في شان
نتابع هذه التظاهرات معك ومع الزملاء
بتغطياتنا غدا اسمح لي ان اعود الى لندن
مصطفى زارو مصطفى لو سمحت يعني وقت قصير
همم لقطات من التظاهر التي هي وراء مباشره
ابدا ابدا اولا انك كانت هناك مظاهره
للممرضين الذين كانوا يعني يحتجون امام
مختلف المستشفيات ولكن
انتقلوا الى امام مقر الرئاسه وهناك ايضا
مظاهره لدعم اوكرانيا تقول هؤلاء
المظاهرون انهم يريدون ان ان تقدم الحكومه
البريطانيه المساعدات اكثر وباسرع وقت
ممكن بالاضافه الى هؤلاء الذين تظاهرون
يتعلق الامر بقانون يتعلق بالمساواه في
المملكه المتحده شكرا لك مصطفى زهره مراسل
العربيه وايضا من باريس فادي دهوك مراسل
العربيه
قطاع الصحفي ماءزق سواء مع هذه الاضطرابات
او من دونها هكذا يقول العشرات من هؤلاء
الممرضين الذين بداوا اول يوم في اضراب
مقرر لمده يومين طبعا هناك نقص في
الموظفين ممرضون منهكون واطباء ايضا لا
تنتهي لائحه مرضاهم كل جميع هذه العوامل
جعلت من قطاع الصحه قطاع هارم يقول طبعا
الممرضون هنا بانهم هم اكثر من يدفع ثمن
فشل الحكومه
هاي همم
وهذه طبعا النقابات تقول بانها فقط
البدايه في سلسله من الاضرابات هناك اضراب
مقرر اكبر اضراب في الاول من فبراير
بالاضافه الى توعد نقابات الممرضين الى
اضراب السادس والسابع من فبراير كل هذا
يجري فيما يستمر اصطدام بين ريش السوناتا
والاحزاب المعارضه في مجلس العموم
[تصفيق]
وبسق بموقفها من رفع الاجور هكذا كان
المشهد هنا في لندن ننتقل الى باريس عند
فادي لنقل المشهد من هنالك
اسود يشمل اضرابا وتظاهرتا تقول انها
ستكون مليونيه في اكبر تحرك احتجاجيا يقوم
به الفرنسيون منذ عام 1995 الحكومه تحذر
من ان السماحه للمعترضين بالاحتجاج على
قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد وارتفاع الاسعار
لا يعني سماحها بشل وتعطي للمؤسسات تحذير
لا يابه به
يعني
الحكومه هي من تعطل البلد وملايين الاشخاص
هي تحاول ان تجعلنا نصدمه مع الناس
متناسقه ان الاكثريه منهم ضد رفع سن
التقاعد
احلام كثيرين من كانوا يستعدون لمغادره
عملهم في سن الثانيه والستين
وبسعود كبير
1966 ساجد نفسي في نهايه الخدمه مسن جدا
ولن اتمكن من الاستمتاع بالتقاعد محطه
القطار ومترو الانفاق هذا ستخلو من
المسافرين يوم الاضراب لكن المشهد سيكون
مختلفا في الشوارع اذ تشير مذكره
للاستخبارات الفرنسيه بان التظاهرات ستجمع
ما بين 500,000 الى 700,000 متظاهرا ستحشد
لهم السلطات 10 الاف
لمواجهه اعمال عنف متوقعه فادي دهوك
العربيه باريس
[موسيقى]
بعد الغواصات ها هي استراليا تتخلى هذه
المره عن مروحيات فرنسيه
وتستبدلها ببلاك هوك الامريكيه وفي
التفاصيل كشفت وزاره الدفاع الاستراليه
انه سيتم استبدال مروحيات فرنسيه من نوع
باخرى امريكيه من نوع بلاك هوك الامريكيه
على الرغم من الجهود الحثيثه التي بذلتها
باريس في اللحظات الاخيره لانقاذ الاتفاق
الحكومه الاستراليه قالت انها معذوره
ولديها الاسباب الكافيه وهي ان نفقات
صيانه المروحيات الفرنسيه مكلفه جدا ولم
تحصل على ساعات الطيران التي تحتاج اليها
من هذه المروحيات
والثقه اذا بين البلدين كانت قد تراجعت
عام 2021 عندما الغت استراليا بشكل مفاجئ
صفقه بقيمه اثنين 62 مليار دولار امريكي
مع فرنسا طبعا انا ذاك لش غواصات
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه الحديث هذا الموضوع حسيني يعني
هلا بدات ردود الفعل الفرنسيه حول هذه
الازمه الجديده وهل بدا الحديث عن يعني
انحسار ما كان يعرف
مع ايضا الانحسار الماضي
في الواقع كانت فرنسا استبشرت خيرا بوصول
انطوني البنيز على راس الحكومه الاستراليه
وهو من الحزب العمالي ليحل محل اسكت
ماريسون الذي تحمله باريس وهو المنتمي الى
الحزب الليبرالي في استراليا تحمله
مسؤوليه الغاء صفقه الغواصات الفرنسيه
لاستراليا عام 2001
وهذه صفقه كانت قيمتها تبلغ حوالي 90
مليار يورو وطبعا قيمه صفقه المروحيات
التي الغيت حديثا لا تقارن ابدا بالتسعين
مليار يورو لان قيمه صفقه المروحيات لا
تتجاوز المليارات يورو ومع ذلك فانها
الضربه للصناعات العسكريه الاوروبيه لانها
المره الثانيه خلال اقل من عام ونصف التي
تدير فيها استراليا ظاهرها للصناعات
العسكريه الاوروبيه
تحيات التي الغيت صفقتها هي من طراز ام ار
اتش 90 وتقوم بصناعه هذه المروحيات يقوم
بصناعتها كونسوارسيوم صناعي اوروبي يتالف
من اربيوس للمروحيات ومجموعه ليوناردو
الايطاليه ومجموعه فكر الهولنديه هذا
الكونسوارسيوم الصناعي الاوروبي خسر صفقه
المليارات يورو قيمه المروحيات الاربعين
ولكن طبعا ما زالت هناك صفقه تتعلق ببيعه
همم مصفحات خفيفه اوروبيه لاستراليا ولكن
هذا طبعا لا يعوض الخساره الكبيره بالنسبه
لردود الفعل وحدها شركه اصدرت بيان قالت
فيه انها اخذت علما بالقرار الاسترالي
اللي ناحيه الغاء صفقه المروحيات ومع ذلك
وبعيد عن هذا هذا القرار فاناويس ستواصل
الاهتمام بتطوير حضورها مهم في السوق
الاستراليه هذا هو رد الفعل الوحيد الذي
صدر حتى الان على القرار الاسترالي لايال
شكرا لك حسين على هذه الرساله وسيطنا
بمراسل العربيه من باريس
[موسيقى]
يعرض ما زاد علني مقتنيات من شركه تويتر
الاساسيه في سان فرانسيسكو للبيع وتضم
المقتنيات اساسا مكتبيا الحاله اثارت
سخريه البعض بعد ما تسببت اداره الملك
الجديد الى ماسك بناكسات مستمره للطائر
الازرق
كرسي واله قهوه طويله ومعدله مطبخيه ليست
اثاث بيت يريد اصحابه الهجره بل هي
مقتضيات اكبر الشركات التكنولوجيه في
العالم الطاقه الحرب تويتر بعد انعازف عنه
اثر التغييرات التي اجراها الملك الجديد
دولار تعرض 636 قطعه من مبداها في
كاليفورنيا على الموقع
اله القهوه
هذا الشعار البسيط الذي قد يمر به
الموظفون يوميا وهم غير بوجود تجاوز ثمنه
ثمانيه الف دولار
مبالغ لم تحل ازمه تويتر الماليه الا انها
على مبدا القليل قد يسند الحال
[موسيقى]
لمسك الذي عجز عن دفع ايجار الشركه ما
تسبب برفع الدعوه والقضائيه عليه في الوقت
الذي يحاول فيه مالك الطائر الازرق يخفض
النفقات بشكل كبير
ويزيد الدخل باي وسيله
المنتخب
الزراعه لتحديد موقع غرس نباتات الذره في
الحقل الواقع بمنطقه لوس كوندوريس حتى
تظهر او الذره بعد نموها على هيئه وجه
النجم الارجنت
ختام التاسع مشاهدينا مع العناوين
وبعد ما استنفذ مستودعاته بالولايات
المتحده البنتاجون يلجا الى مخازينه
السريه في اسرائيل لامداد الجيش الاوكراني
في اليمن ويؤكد ان اقناع الحوثيين بالسلام
سيفتحوا الباب امام محل سياسي
[موسيقى]
الاضرابات تتعب القطاعات الحيويه في دول
الماء الصحه والتعليم في بريطانيا
والتقاعد والنقل في فرنسا
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
الزميل طاهر طاهر مساء الخير وماذا لديك
نحن سنركز على الحمله الاعلاميه الضاريه
في ايران ضد محمد شياع السوداني في العراق
اضافه الى تسلا هل تتحول فعلا الى كابوس
عند ماسك بدل النجوميه التي تلقاها منها